hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 World Championship match between
Robert James Fischer and Boris
vasilyevitch Spassky it's game 20 and if
you've been with us so far you know that
the previous six games have been drawn
and the Fischer is still three points in
the lead Spassky now has the black
pieces and it seems that pretty much
everyone knows that it will it is highly
unlikely this basket will come back to
equalize in this match and even win this
match dr. max we feed a president
already arrived in Reykjavik getting
ready for the final ceremony and
everything and a lot of players for
example even a from spassky's camp
decided to leave for for Moscow and most
of the most of the things off the board
now is no longer about the cameras about
anything but it's actually about the
prize money now it seems that the prize
fund is will be subject to taxes but the
the Federation of Reykjavik decided that
they will not submit this prize won a
fund to the taxes they decided to make
an exception this time well thinking
that in good faith as possible not have
to pay taxes for his winnings when he
gets back home to the Soviet Union and
that Fischer will not have to pay taxes
for his winnings when he returns home to
the United States if he does and it
seems like that will be going well but
we're gonna discuss that a bit more and
the Fischer's a legal representative and
mr. Paul Marshall I said that he found
fish or some nice work when he gets back
home into the United States all of the
jobs that he found for him were some six
figures big and they were mostly about
signing autographs and playing a few
simultaneous exhibitions but you know
even if he doesn't get the money and his
accounts get frozen he was to be able to
at least get something somehow but you
know he still has to win this match even
though his three points in the lead so
Fischer has the white pieces and in this
game he opens with E for later after the
match both of the players said that
their favorite move for this match was a
when they played whitey 400 kc5
spassky's again interested in a fight we
have Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and d4c
captures Knight captures Knight to f6
Knight to c3 g6 and Fischer does not go
for his favorite sozin but rather again
he repeats the Richter Raza variation
from the 18th game and ok e6 Spassky
doesn't mind playing the exact same
variation we have Queen to d2 a6 we have
a queenside castle brush up to d7 and
now f4 Bishop to e7 this is the exact
same game the two of them played in the
18th game and here Fischer if you
remember continued with Knight to f3 he
prepared e5 but for this game he
prepared Bishop to e2 it's a very rare
move that was to this game played only
three times before and it comes with the
idea of simply developing a piece and
preparing to bring this Bishop over to
f3 at the Hindu black Black's
development of the Queen side that would
be 5 it's okay we have castles by
Spassky playing something like h6
doesn't really work here with the idea
of rush up to 84 and now capturing on e4
because Knight can simply capture on e4
and after Bishop captures an h4 you have
this Knight captures on d6 check that's
the problem
King to f8 and of course white white is
much better here you can simply attack
the bishop and now the threat is either
capturing here and then capturing an f7
would a double attack being created
against the bishop on d7 and whatever
black plays let's say Bishop to e7 he
will still capture on f7 King captures
and our queen can capture here captures
captures and it will be a much better
position for white so after this
Fischer's in Bishop to e2 we have
castles by Spassky and now comes the
Bishop to f3 and now of course b5 would
be a bit too early as if I'm not will
win you the game there's an attack
against your knight on f6 and also this
comes with a double attack against the
knight on c6 if you capture of course
you will lose the rook on a8
so here h6 is played and here Fischer
goes Bishop to h4 also a possibility
here and a very interesting one is
definitely h4 or something well you
would play in the Blitz game but here
it's not so clear black can simply
you know you and continue playing this
game either by starting to develop on
the queenside he can capture on d4 and
then you always have to figure out -
what will you do here now I mean you can
always of course capture an f6 but if it
doesn't work better not play it so
Fisher simply allows the following
simplification as his three points in
the lead in this match and here he
really doesn't mind any simplifications
Bishop to h4 is played and now Spassky
does go for Knight captures on e4 Bishop
captures on e7 by Fischer if you play
Knight captures on e4 first and allow
Bishop captures on h4 then Knight
captures on d6 comes but practice showed
that black will be better after coming
to c7 attacking the knight on d6 and
after Knight characters Bishop captures
Bishop captures on c6 Queen captures on
c6 the material on the board is equal
but black has a bishop against the night
and this dark square bishop when it
comes back to f6 will be extremely
powerful the rooks can come easily to
the open files and black can just start
pushing his pawns on the Queen side all
in all black would be better here so
instead Bishop captures on e7 and now
comes Knight captures on d2 not Knight
captures an e7 because now we have this
Knight captures on c6 with the threat of
first capturing on e7 with check so now
if you Knight capture some d2 knife
captors on e7 comes with check King has
to move and only now will you recapture
and here of course you would be up a
piece as white and there's really
nothing you can do even if you trap this
night there wouldn't really help you
rook captures here rook captures and
Albert kappa77 still you would be up up
a whole night it would a better position
completely winning for white so after
Bishop captures on a 7 knife capture
Sundy to this sir these are all very
known simplifications
Bishop captures on d8 Knight captures on
f3 Knight captures on f3
rook F captures on d8 and now rook
captures on d6 and came to f8 preparing
to bring the King over to e7 I will have
rook H to d1 doubling up on the D file
and now came to e7 defending the bishop
on d7 that was attacked twice Knight to
a4 preparing to play Knight to be six or
even like to c5 but it would be a
problematic for black so a bishop to yet
first Spassky forces a trader rooks we
have rook captures rook captures and now
Knights the c5 if Fischer immediately
exchanges the other pair of rooks as
well with rope captures 19 captures add
the King will be much closer to defender
the King side pawns so Fisher go decides
against this we have nice to see five
attacking the pawn on b7 rook to b8
defending it if rook captures and e1
with check then King captures in the
Knights the d8 okay this defends the
Queen side but it's very unlikely that
you would be able to push for anything
here with the black pieces it's hard as
it is but Spassky has to has to create
chances we have rook to b8 and now comes
Luke to d3 as Spassky decided to go play
this game and did not go into this ROIs
line Fischer now wants to play rook to
b3 and question spassky's position here
on the Queen side we have a five here as
the b7 pawn can't really be moved as
Knight captures on a6 would be played
first a5 and not preparing b5 fresher
first place rook the b3 he forces
passkey to push his beep on would have
b5 and now comes a three we have a for
attacking Fischer's look and now road
back to c3 and now spassky's two points
on the Queen side are controlling
Fischer's three points on the Queen side
very nicely but there are some dark
square weaknesses on the Queen side rook
to d8 now the rook is no longer useful
here you can simply shift it to control
the D file and now tonight's to d3
closing the D file and perhaps planning
Knight to e5 so Spassky prevented with
f6 wrote the c5 attacking the b5 pawn
and now rook comes back to b8 to guard
the pawn rook the c3 and now comes g5 we
have a g3 by Fischer not allowing the
Spassky to mobilize his a huge pawn mass
on the King side and in 36 possible now
try to increase the activity of his
skinny Knights the c5 and now comes
g4 as poss he doesn't mind
this static position that will be
created on the kingside but as it does
give him some more activity he will have
now more dark square weaknesses on the
kingside as well
Knights the e4 this comes with check
King has to protect the f6 pawn so King
to e7 and now comes Knights the e1 rook
to d8 and now comes some Knights to d3
we have looked to d4 and now Knight back
to f2 attacking the g4 pawn
so h5 simply defending the pawn roped
the c5 and now Spassky has to deal with
Fischer is a very strong rook and c5 so
he offers the exchange rook to d5 and
here if if Fischer would accept this
role captures pawn captures then Spassky
scheme is a bit more active and his
pieces are more active at the bishop
would be very strong here and spassky's
pawns are now controlling a lot more
space so it would have been a better
minor piece end game for Spassky so
Fischer of course the clients this he
goes rook to c3 and now comes Knight
back to d4 rook the c7 would check as
here Spassky was threatening Knight to
e2 with a width check to pick up the
rook so first rook to c7 check rook to
d7 Spassky offers a trade and here
Fischer accepts it rook captures Bishop
captures and here comes Knight to e1 not
allowing Spassky to create an outpost
for his knight on f3 we have E 5 by
Spassky F captures F captors and King to
D - we have Bishop to a5 now gaining
control of d4 square not allowing this
knife to get activated which Knight to
e4 and also the knight and Bishop are
pressuring the c2 pawn the King has to
keep an eye on it or or he will have to
push it to c3 but that will further
create weaknesses on the Queen side so
Knights the d1 preparing move Knight to
e3 to activate the knight this way and
here we have King the beast 6 this is
the move Spassky played and this is the
move that was sealed so the game was
adjourned here and it will be continued
tomorrow and as League which mentions in
his book it doesn't make sense to simply
improve the position of the King cannot
make any rash moves with the pawns or
with the pieces and then analyze the
position over the entire night and
decide what what is best here
so when the game was continued
unfortunately this is one of the few
games where glitch does not mention if
Fischer came on time but as the one time
that Fischer did common time he
mentioned it so I will assume that
official was again late for the
continuation of the game but ok nice the
three attacking the bishop on f5 this is
Fischer's continued movement now Bishop
to e6 we have came to d3 and now Bishop
to f7 trying to meet Fischer's advance
of the King King e4 with this Bishop to
d6 check at this would of course win the
game for Spassky as the King has nowhere
to go
you would have to block with the night
and then Bishop capture simply wins you
a piece and of course the game so after
Bishop to f7 Fischer simply moved the
King King to c3 and now we have King to
c6 came back to d3 by Fisher King to c5
and now kink the ephors Pascal House
officials King to enter here to attack
the pawn as if if Spassky wants to
create chances for him to win the game
he also has to allow for some chances
otherwise there's really nothing to do
here and King the d6 simply moving the
King back at defending the pawn especial
to g6 isn't all that impressive now as
d5 phone is unguarded Fischer can simply
capture it and there's there are no
threats against the siege upon as both
of Fischer's Knights are defending it so
after King to e4 we have kinked the d6
defending the pawn and now Fischer
simply moves back King to d3
he's more than satisfied with it raw
it's already game 20 his three points in
the lead in the match
if Spassky wants to create something he
will have to push harder than this push
up to g6 check and now goes came back to
c3 King to c5 and now comes Knights to
d3 attacking the e5 pawn and here came
back to d6 defending Knights the e1
again not allowing this night to come to
f3 and here King to c6 was played it's
interesting but Knight to f3 is not
enough for black because here if Knight
captures on f3 pawn captures and King to
d2
black will try something the King can
even come very close into the position
but after king he want king d4 and King
to have to theirs
not all that much black can do here for
example if F or then comes h4 and this
formation of g3 and h4 these two pawns
are on dark squares so spassky's light
square bishop will be a very little use
here these two points are creating a
wall against Spassky skink so he can
never approach the position you can't
really do anything but pushing of the
points all the important points on the
queenside on dark squares as well and
Spassky can just move the King here or
dance around with his Bishop Fisher was
simply repeat moves 91 93 91 93 and
there's really nothing to do here so
unfortunately this does not work Knight
to f3
so Spassky tried to King to c6 but now
comes King d2 officiais again satisfied
with a draw not trying anything
King c5 Knight to d3 would check King
most nights the II 196 by Spassky King
to see three and here's possibly played
knight to d4 and Fischer called the
chief arbiter lost her Schmidt and he
said he wanted to well he said that it's
a draw by threefold repetition and
Spassky didn't even wait for a lot of
Schmidt to check he just signed the
Fisher's claim for a draw and the game
was drawn here but in fact it was not a
threefold repetition is it was only a
two-fold repetition but I I mean there's
really no way for Spassky to push for
anything here but you know he could have
waited but obviously he was satisfied
with a draw so even with twofold
repetition he you know he acknowledged
Fischer's claim for a draw so that's a
game xx I do hope you enjoyed it the
result is now eleven and a half to eight
and a half in Fischer's favor so still
three points in the lead that we are
getting very close to the end of this
spectacular match so you know definitely
stay tuned I would like to thank Michael
Hildebrand
Michael Cabral Patrick McKibben's Nancy
Trotman and the Mark Lefebre for
contributing to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos your
thing called for watching and I will see
you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content definitely I will finish this
series before the start of the course in
Caruana match in November and also I
would like to wish a happy birthday to
martavis Paul Coski from Poland
it's a couple of days late but I hope
you had a very nice celebration so thank
you all and I will see you soon